dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IIFA here AI
research has come a long long way in the
last few years not so long ago we were
lucky if we could train a neural network
to understand traffic science and since
then so many things happened by
harnessing the power of learning
algorithms we are now able to
impersonate other people by using a
consumer camera generate high quality
virtual human faces for people that
don't exist or pretend to be able to
dance as a pro dancer by using an
external video footage and transferring
it onto ourselves even though we are
progressing at a staggering pace there's
a lot of debate as to which research
direction is the most promising going
forward roughly speaking there are two
schools of thought one we recently
talked about Richard Sutton's amazing
article by the name the bitter lesson in
which he makes a great argument that AI
research should not try to mimic the way
the human brain works
he argues that instead all we need to do
is formulate our problems in a general
manner so that our learning algorithm
may find something that is potentially
much better suited for a problem than
our brain is I put a link to this video
in the description if you're interested
and to a different school of thought
says that we should look at all these
learning algorithms that use a lot of
powerful hardware and can do wondrous
things like playing a bunch of Atari
games at a superhuman level however they
learn orders of magnitude slower than
the human brain does so it should
definitely be worth it to try to study
and model the human brain at least until
we can match it in terms of efficiency
this school of thought is what we are
going to talk about in this video as an
example let's take a look at deep
reinforcement learning in the context of
playing computer games
this technique is a combination of a
neural network that processes the visual
data that we see on the screen and a
reinforcement learner that comes up with
the gameplay related decisions
absolutely amazing algorithm a true
breakthrough in AI research very
powerful
however also quite slow and by slow I
mean that we can sit for an hour in
front of our computer and wonder why our
learner does not work at all because it
loses all of its lives almost
immediately if we remain patient we find
out that it works it just learns at a
glacial pace so why is this so slow well
two reasons reason number one is that
the learning happens through incremental
parameter adjustment if a human fails
really badly at a task the human would
know that a drastic adjustment to the
strategy is necessary while the deep
reinforcement learner would start
applying tiny tiny changes to its
behavior and test again if things got
better this takes a while and as a
result seems unlikely to have a close
relation to how we humans think the
second reason for it being slow is the
presence of weak inductive bias this
means that the learner does not contain
any information about the problem we
have at hand or in other words has never
seen the game we are playing before and
has no other previous knowledge about
games at all this is desirable in some
cases because we can reuse one learning
algorithm for a variety of problems
however because this way the AI has to
test a stupendously large number of
potential hypotheses about the game we
will have to pay for this convenience by
using a mighty inefficient algorithm but
is this all really true does deep
reinforcement learning really have to be
so slow and what on earth does this have
to do with our brain well this paper
proposes an interesting counter-argument
that this is not necessarily true and
argues that with a few changes the
efficiency of deep reinforcement
learning may be drastically improved and
get this it also tells us that these
changes are also possibly based in
neuroscience one such change is using
episodic memory which stores previous
experiences to help estimating the
potential value of different actions in
this way drastic parameter adjustments
become a possibility and it not only
improves the
efficiency but there is more to it
because there are recent studies that
show that using episodic memory indeed
contributes to the learning of real
humans and animals alike and to it is
beneficial to let the AI implement its
own reinforcement learning algorithm the
concept often referred to as learning to
learn or matter reinforcement learning
this also helps obtaining more general
knowledge that can be reused across
tasks further improving the efficiency
of the agent here you see a picture of
an fMRI and some regions are marked with
yellow and orange here what could these
possibly mean well hold on to your
papers because these highlight neural
structures that implement a very similar
matauri enforcement learning scheme
within the human brain it turns out that
metal reinforcement learning or dis
learning to learn scheme may not just be
something that speeds up our AI
algorithms but may be a fundamental
principle of the human brain as well so
these two changes to deep reinforcement
learning not only drastically improve
its efficiency but it also suddenly Maps
quite a bit better to our brain how cool
is that
so which school of thought are you most
fond of should we model the brain or
should we listen to Richard Sutton's
bitter lesson let me know in the
comments also make sure to have a look
at the paper I found it to be quite
readable and you really don't need to be
a neuroscientist to read it and learn
quite a few new things make sure to have
a look at it in the video description
now I think you notice that this paper
doesn't contain the usual visual of
fireworks and is more complex than your
average two minute papers video and
hence I expect it to get significantly
less views that's not a great business
model but you know what I made this
channel so I can share with you all
these important lessons that I learned
during my journey this has been a true
privilege and I am thrilled that I am
still able to talk about all these
amazing papers without worrying too much
whether any of these videos will go
viral or not this has only been possible
because of your unwavering support on
patreon.com slash two minute papers
if you feel like chipping in please
click the patreon link in the video
description and if you're more like a
crypto person we also support crypto
currencies like Bitcoin aetherium and
litecoin the addresses are also
available in the video description
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time